[Music]
welcome to ear abyss ckets I'm Rhett and
I'm link our guests on this week's show
is they wanted only philip defranco had
quite a conversation with phil that
you're going to enjoy if you enjoy
amazing life details of narrow escapes
from death and just crazy happenings
narrow escapes from weird relationship
this guy has lived quite a life and we
had quite a conversation with him that
we're anxious for you to hear and he
just got engaged talking about what he
thinks of marriage you know what we
think of marriage okay you know buckle
up for that but first I did want to ask
you if you thought that we me and you
you're asking me not them yeah we're
gonna go surfing tomorrow morning
because we've been going a lot of people
don't know this we haven't been talking
about it
we've been going every week for the past
month and then we took two weeks off cuz
we got too busy and I think a static
stand-up paddleboarding slash surfing
yeah basically trying to teach ourselves
to surf at Will Rogers okay well don't
tell him where we're going because they
might show up and or something it's
funny because I was trying to say teach
ourselves to surf when no one's there so
we won't be embarrassed and Here I am
saying where it is and well or they
don't know what how are we go out to and
they don't know what time we get there
and and we didn't mention the masks that
we wear that's right that make us look
like mermen
but yeah I'm I I have a hankering to go
back I am over my injury I'm correct a
rib eye yeah I mean I thought it was
just a bruised rib but then you know
after three weeks it doesn't feel any
better
that's a cracked ribs I mean you take a
deep breath now and is it still hurt no
I'm recovered which means I can go out
and reinjure myself okay so I'm ready to
do that
yeah so it's a emitted Lee it's a little
bit dorky two grown men out there on
these very large boards I
think it's cute falling falling down
quite a bit I was I gotta say I did have
a very self conscious conscious moment
because we got out there and there was a
high school surfing class that was
occupying the same strand of beach and
there's all these high school girls out
there you know to see you move down the
beach once they really started coming
out I was like I don't want to be around
these high schoolers I know how it is in
high school they're gonna start bullying
me they're gonna make fun of me the tall
guy in the wetsuit on the stand-up
paddleboard they're only cool surfacer I
stayed down there saw that where they
were you fall off your board a few times
after I embarrassed myself I decided to
paddle I did the paddle of shame you ask
all the high schoolers and at one point
these two high school girls heckled me
yeah I saw that and heard it they said
hey paddle boarder and also paddle
boarders and I was like good morning
what what do you are you a group or
something he said we're a class we're
learning to surf you maybe you would
want to get a real surfboard heckled me
and I was like well I didn't know what I
know you know what am i they did they
said that that you should get a real
surfboard
I said why why don't you tell someone
your own age like I just didn't have a
good response
well that's true if there was a camera
there I would have had a great rest with
a catalyst for paddling high schoolers I
don't know I didn't know that you heard
that they heckled me cuz you didn't say
anything you didn't why didn't you yell
I leave my friend alone because I know
my place man I was outside of the break
and I was like I mean you were right
there I'm gonna stay out of this he's
being made fun of by high schoolers I'm
gonna watch and laugh internally yeah
well we'll talk about it later that's
what I was thinking we talked about it
later
you could have stood up for me man okay
tomorrow if they they say the same
things
I'll stick up for you be don't talk to
my friend guys like what you did to John
Carson and yeah great John Carson was
picking on you and I punched him in the
stomach
I should make up for that
okay we'll settle that later so I owe
you is that what you see that's the
you're not gonna help me with hecklers
until I make good on the John Carson
thing that you did true so I'll go into
the fray tomorrow and see if they make
fun of me and then you can punch
somebody okay we had a great
conversation like we said with Philip
DeFranco so we don't want to delay
getting into this thing any further but
just a couple of things in terms of bio
here if you don't know who Philly D is
he's been on YouTube since it's
basically the very beginning in 2006 he
has amassed over a billion views on just
his show the philip defranco show
that's quite a landmark and he's also
the creator of the SourceFed channels
which we're friends with those people
too so what one one word of warning
before we get into this conversation
like we said on last week's show this
show is not necessarily family-friendly
and I would say this is one of those
episodes where we had a great raw open
and honest conversation with Phil about
a number of things but it's not a
conversation that's appropriate for kids
I'm very kid and you're listening right
now you need to go find something else
to do and if you're an adult that has a
kid watching you need to send the kid
out here it is our conversation with
Philip DeFranco now we saw you I guess
it was two weeks ago we came to your
place right through the SourceFed thing
and when we did the table talk all of a
sudden when that was done we started
talking about marriage no you are now
engaged I definitely want to get into
that I don't want to start there I just
want to acknowledge that that's never
gonna go we've actually we're definitely
go there we've got what 25 years of
marriage between the two of us but not
with each other I might want to clarify
that I think that it's not fair that you
get you just add it like if two things
happen at the same it's fair yeah it
well that's because you're experienced
what difference it's like when you go to
a new plumber and they're like we have
477 years of plumbing experience that's
not one really old plumber no it's like
twelve no it's like twenty five guys who
you know have been
for a few years so that's what we're
offering you perfect later on in this
podcast is you know to really get into
this whole the concept of marriage and
what's what's ahead for you sir so
you're saying that we're gonna be
teaching Phil something later is that I
just filled it to up - yeah I just think
back to talk about it a little bit if
you have any questions we're not
necessarily gonna have good answers but
you know it's not about us anyway
there's two of us there's one of you you
need to speak more but we should go back
to the origin first like the origin of
Philip DeFranco the night of your
conception it was a sloppy sloppy night
it was a mistake really well that's my
dad always says that I was the best
mistake he ever made but I feel like
that's what probably 70% of parents say
at this point in life like most I feel
like my parents never said that to me
but but we don't know how to take that
but were you planned I never asked no I
think I was maybe I think I was well
also uh my my parents are divorced or
your parents still together
minor divorce so divorce still together
okay well cuz in the in a divorce it
usually comes up because usually you're
kind of even though you're not the
problem like you were part of that
equation as a child and it adds to the
situation no one wants to be like Tim it
was your fault okay so you were the you
were the accident yes and then it was
your fault that they got a divorce is
that what you're saying no no no it was
my fault that those poor people decided
okay we're having a baby let's try and
like do this oh you were the cause of
the marriage it will I you know what I'm
such a bad memory I don't know I
literally were pretty small it was such
a volatile relationship back then like
if they start talking about the past I'm
like good I'm done I'll see you guys
later because it's just that was
actually the reason why I was so scared
of marriage for the longest time because
that relationship was terrible and the
only reason they had to like even
remotely stay together or know each
other anymore was me hmm and then seeing
the relationships after but I mean one
of the reasons I I do believe that
marriage can work and maybe it's because
I also haven't talked to you guys yet is
my dad my dad and my stepmom best
relationship I've ever seen like
they just love each other they take care
of each other for better or worse richer
or poorer sickness and in health like
they abide by the vowels yeah and they
rock it see we're already we're already
back to the marriage I know it's already
full circle so okay so you were born
into this into this marriage which this
is the first one which was destined to
not doesn't did not work not work yes
but we're always only offspring from
that that union yes yeah I have a
half-brother from a mom's side that's
about 10 years older than me and a
half-sister on my my dad's side that's
10 years younger than me you stay in
touch with them my sister more than my
brother there's I think there it's just
even most of my family I don't I don't
have that much of a connection to them
it's it's very mom dad immediate family
don't really know many of the others we
recently saw that like my dad my uncle
and some of my cousins were out in
Anaheim and we met one time and then I
was like that was cool but I don't I
don't know I always thought that I was a
family person but when it was fun
they're cool people but I don't know if
there's any reason to keep up with it
right yeah well I might be getting in
touch with some of my third to fifth
cousins soon because if yeah because
Linc and I are doing this DNA analysis
thing online where they tell you all
about it who you are where you come from
and they start telling you when you're
third to fifth cousins start contacting
you so if you want to hang out with any
of my 35th cousins is this that 23andme
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I messed around
with that and it's really it's really
interesting the thing that throws me off
is when it's like doesn't say undecided
it's like unknown have you gotten the
results yet oh yeah okay I have not
looked at my results so don't spoil them
for me okay yeah you have them right I
have mine no you don't have mine no not
yours yet okay good I'm gonna talk to
them you can't spoil them I guess it's
just oh no it is interesting to think of
like where where you come from but you
come from unknown well I come from parts
unknown I'm mostly European not as
Italian as I thought I was
disappointment but no I mean it's one of
those things that it's like it's
interesting so you can mention it but
I'm a very live in the now and I don't
mean that like I'm
thing out of airplanes but just like I
don't my brain can only handle so much
yeah so you're so you're not necessarily
connecting I mean for for us I think
it's like you know moving out here to to
the to the west coast it's like you
don't you start you definitely desire to
connect with the people that you're in
close proximity to so you don't have
family out here so I mean other you know
Lindsay's your your fiancee we know her
yes and I mean who else are you
connecting with if you're not connecting
with your your half-brother and
half-sister really just the people
around me and it becomes it becomes this
weird mishmash of there are times where
I try to not hire my friends because I
don't want to employ everyone I know
because it changes the relationship oh
yeah but they're not called friends
they're called an entourage
no no well that's the thing is like it
isn't what they're doing for you yes yes
yes well it's not like I'm like one of
those like football players that like
brings like 40 of their friends to their
house and like has their cell phone
bills and and like and it's like oh and
he drives my car like I mean it's like
right you know I I we were all out here
most of us are tubers that's how we met
in the first place and we all have kind
of the same goal so you know I like Joe
Bereta hired Joe Bereta I consider him a
friend but it's not like we're like best
friends I think you have to have the
those lines but for the most part I have
about three close friends my fiancee and
then that's kind of it I keep it small
I'm a very boring homebody kind of
person unless I'm like oh yeah we'll go
totally jump out of an airplane and
that'll be fun and then I go straight
back to being boring and I think it's
kind of worked out just because I get to
focus on work a lot and I was thinking
about it on the way here I don't I don't
know I don't know if I want to change
that up that much I'm pretty I'm pretty
happy with it but I don't want to be our
best friend because that was the real
goal here was that we would become like
a trio of best buddies and hang out all
the time and yeah and that doors locked
and that doors locked that's kind of
what's happening on the lighting the
lights out very low
was sketched out when I came here I
looked inside I was like I think that's
a Christmas tree and I rang the doorbell
three times and no one answered
everyone's dead inside that doorbell
goes yeah we need to prop so what was it
like growing up I still want to kind of
track back okay and so and I don't want
to underwhelm you because when I say I
have a terrible memory I really do just
make it up I feel like I feel like if I
talk to like a shrink they'd be like you
were pressing stuff but we can do the
thing we wrap you in a blanket and you
emerge from the womb again and then
maybe like go through the whole thing
and the whole process ago go to your
first memory we have a blanket blocking
the doors dimming the lights now we got
the blanket I know what you mean though
it's you know I I always questioned
whether I'm suppressing something -
because my mobile my memories of
childhood are kind of sketchy yeah it's
like they're not all there is that what
you mean you don't remember much of the
like you know the grade school where did
you where did you grow up do you
remember the state yes no no yes I was
born I was born in New York specifically
the Bronx and I was there for about 10
to 12 years once again the kind of how
can remember it so you left in middle
school ish I think middle schooler right
before okay probably
Jerry Berg can try do the math so this
is with both parents no just with so my
parents are split at this point my mom
wants to move us out to North Carolina
my my grandpa lives out there just start
fresh they have this whole battle of you
know can you leave the state you can you
can't visitation and so my mom moves to
to North Carolina my dad ends up a year
later moving to Florida and so I kind of
do this back and forth thing so and
we're in North Carolina Asheville North
Carolina the land of old people and
hippies actually I mean that in a
positive way it's like it's accurate
yeah but I love it like it's a weird
intersection of people there yeah and I
don't know I haven't been back in I want
to say about four to six years mainly
because I'm terrified of tiny planes and
that Airport is tiny as well and I don't
want I also don't want to go to
Charlotte and any plane landing on a
mountaintop is precarious that's what
freaks me out no I mean one of the
scariest experiences of my life
was we were going to the the RNC in
Florida and somehow I guess we we booked
our tickets late and I was on a plane
that had six people and I was like and
it like has the hump for the for the
wheel and I was like this is how I die
I'm gonna die in a plane that not even a
report was like crashed because it's so
small they might think that was a car
accident
everyone's getting on there asking is it
you know and do you know how to fly
plane right do you know it's like
checking people off the list when I got
an exact but I can see into the end of
the cockpit and and there's not a door
it's just curtains how do we even get
chicken that comes out you've been to
the Asheville Airport I know what that's
like yeah
so you grew up from like middle school
at the middle school years you moved
with your mom to the Asheville to
Asheville North Carolina and so that's
yeah that's where I I went to middle
school and that if you ever saw my draw
my life video at some point my mom ended
up getting into a relationship with a
guy that was under illegal activities
and she got cancer at the same time that
this guy was getting busted I'm sorry I
didn't want your drug is so I'm afraid
of drawings about people's lives
terrifying
I hate feds you gotta give it I like you
to give it to me here at the roundtable
but they want you to draw it here on the
table right here right over Grace's name
answer how illegal cancer story is don't
get involved with the legal activities
so yeah my my mom starts dating this
this awesome guy he owns a bar it's
really cool I get to play darts there to
people it's where I learned how to play
pool it was just this kind of fun time
even though when I look back on it now
you know it's kind of sketchy as all
hell and then we we move in with with
this guy and then things are really good
for a little bit and then one day I
heard some something on the rafters for
a better word and we didn't really have
an attic space so I was like when was
that
and so he left and I decided to go in
there and see what was up and I find
this really weird giant jar of mustard
not a jar isn't even it's just a giant
like you went to Costco he was addicted
to mustard he was addicted
not a problem but there was mustered all
dripped on the sides and I was like what
the hell was that about and so it looked
like someone had just like put something
in there and I looked in and I dipped my
hand in a little and there were tons of
bags of pills and it turned out that he
just sold tons of speed like tons and
tons and that and then I showed my mom
and that started this whole thing that
would then go on to the the law getting
involved for a lack of a better way to
explain it her working with that and
then at the same time she found out she
had cancer and so all the time this guy
is helping her get treatment for this
speed money with speed money I guess in
borrowed money and others see some
mustard money um
cancer happened first he was he was
helping with well that's a thing I can't
remember which order it came in I what I
do remember is things got a little weird
and one night we woke up because we
found out we had a carbon monoxide
detector and the way we found that out
was it went off my mom and I went to the
garage and the guy had his the car on he
had a gas mask on and he had everything
closed so all the smoke was just coming
straight into the house and uh yeah and
about a week later my mom was like
you're going with your dad
and I was with my dad for about two
years in Florida and then there was a
whole custody thing again after that
situation was handled I know you're
looking at me like what the hell he just
he tried to kill you and your mom yes I
just have to I wanted to make sure I
wasn't missing stuff no that's yeah I
mean I'm a decent listener but and that
was I think when I'm trying to replay
the incidents in my head I think that
happened and then either just before or
just effort after my mom started working
with law enforcement and that's how yeah
and so anyway so that situation I think
that guy's still in jail somewhere in
North Carolina so your mom is it is
what's the update there she did she what
happened with the cancer she is survived
yeah she's a survivor she's she's now
remarried well she wasn't married to
that guy
she my mom's been married multiple time
but she's married now she's uh she's a
nurse
so she's she there was this point in her
life I guess where she was just like oh
I wanted to start helping people
I need a it was like that one of that
like I need to contribute to the world
and do something good because I've kind
of surrounded myself with lots of bad
things and so she's awesome she's just
rocking it right now she but what was
weird was we went to college and not
just college at the same time I went to
the same College at the same time
because for the for my first year I was
like I'll go to Community School I'll go
to a BTech and and I'll go there and my
mom was like that's what great idea I
will go as well to start getting my
general IDI out of the way and yeah that
was I feel like out of the the drug
situation or having my mom sitting next
to me in English that was way worse that
was way way worse if I could if I could
live life without one of those two
things I would say the second well when
did it hit you that I guess I think a
lot of times as a kid you go through
things and you don't really know how
exceptional the situation is right when
did it hit you that this is pretty
intense like my story is pretty intense
and unusual I don't know I think that's
the weird thing is like I say it to you
and then I say it with a smile because
it's the weirdest thing to me it's so
weird but at the same time and I feel
weird because I was so young and you
know it probably didn't hit me as hard
as everyone else in that situation yeah
but I don't know I maybe I've never
really processed how how terrifying it
was maybe I I don't know I just consider
it like something that happened and in a
weird way because it's so long - it
almost feels like it happened to someone
else
and that's how I feel it kind of like
prior to 7 years ago I almost feel like
that was that was like a different
person when I look back it's like that
was me but I don't know I don't feel
those things I guess I can't I don't get
that of the emotional reaction and I
think like sometimes that scares me
because I'm like a normal person
probably would still feel something I
don't know I mean I feel I know with
Linc I had a pretty idea like childhood
with my parents are still together I was
protected from a lot I know
Lync had there was some tumultuous
relationships yeah my mom and dad split
when I was two and so there was this the
whole visitation custody well there
wasn't in custody battle really but it
was the whole visitation with my dad and
you know the woman that he was with that
he remarried so the whole stepmom thing
it wasn't it was nothing to the extreme
of what you're talking about
but there was certainly a traumatic
thing for a child in retrospect I
remember that it wasn't a happy time for
me but at the same time I wasn't I'm not
I don't remember being scarred I'm don't
feel like I'm scarred now or I don't
remember at the time that it was that
horrible it was just okay this is just
this is just life it could be better it
could be worse
my parents could be together that'd
probably be better but right no yeah I
totally good I think it's weird like now
that I'm thinking about it you know and
I start thinking about when I was talked
about like my mom's been married
multiple times and like a lot of my
childhood I was with my mom my dad only
got custody later on and was because of
those crazy circumstances but what's
interesting is this guy right who did
this this thing that he may have tried
to kill us right he was in a weird way
almost better than than everyone other
than that one instant instance he was
better than every other person my mom
had like ever married or brought in
because the guy before that this I don't
want this to become a pity party like
I'm literally trying to to feel it out
like that guy the drug dealer guy he
took care of us he he took care of me he
would take me out on his like bike and
we would have fun
he eats reads my mom nice until that and
he like and he just and he never hit me
and before that was like there's a drunk
truck driver that would like he taught
me how to play chess so they're like I
always try and look at the positives of
it but and and so like I he was the
reason I would later like join chess
club and I still loved chess but like he
was a crazy alcoholic and he was like he
hit my mom he hit me and then even after
this crazy guy like there was a time
where that guy was terrible and in like
I almost end up feeling bad
that the situation got to that point I
don't know it's just thinking about it's
so weird because it was all these other
terrible people that directly and
inflicted harm to me and then just this
guy that he was into shady and then he
reacted to everything else right no I
know it's like this weird like things
I'm just trying to wrap my head around
because he said like how traumatic it is
did anybody try to kill you once you
moved in with your dad no that's great
that's a better oh you got to go down to
Florida and live with dad yeah for a
little bit and I did I said that was
high school that was just getting into
high school try to think it might have
been last last year of middle school and
then first year of high school and then
it was kind of back and forth for a bit
which was weird okay and see yeah so
what was what was that like you know
just what kind of what kind of kid were
you in high school
boring and people say nerdy like that's
how they usually describe themselves but
I was just like weird kid I was I liked
waking up in the morning watching Dragon
Ball Z going to school doing my homework
there coming home playing video games
until I went to sleep and then repeating
the cycle like I didn't go out that much
my both my both my parents and separate
situations they kind of locked me down
unless it was like a weekend and it was
like a friend that they have like gone
over to that house to vet their like
very very oddly protective especially
when like I talked to people they're
like oh yeah when I was a teenager I
would go out all the time and we'd you
know hang out at someone in this place
and I was like you could do that and
it's amazing like it was I mean maybe
it's also that like my child and
everything I left home as soon as I
could I turned 17 I graduated early and
I was like I'm out I'm out I'm going
straight into a BTEC I have a job I'm
getting a place and getting out and I
think I've probably been just like
running away from home ever since then
like I love my dad and I visit him
probably the most my mom came out for
the first time in three years I hadn't
seen her in three years I didn't realize
it until I saw her and I was like oh my
god like I've just like I've been pushed
like when I say like seven years ago
that seems like a whole different person
I've just tried to push that entire
existence out and be me who has been on
the internet for however long and you
know I still reference my past all the
time but mmm yeah I don't know I don't I
look back and I'm just like I'm really
glad I'm here now right so you got out
of high school early yes and then you
went to I went to a BTech and your mom
will be with my mom for the first year
okay we had a I guess it was English 101
sorry I shouldn't English 101 and it was
a secret
no one knew we were or son and mother
until they thought you were dating it
was yes no until she she told the
teacher and then he decided that it was
a great idea two references and and he
was an example and no his illustrations
I don't even know why he referenced it
she weren't living with your mom you had
moved out you were it's funny that you
said you were trying to get away yet
there she is in your class that's
probably frustrated yes it was
completely frustrating because it's like
I have these classes and she's like oh I
should probably knock out those classes
too
what's terrible a few things one she was
way more popular in school like she
talked to people I was still weird loner
guy - she did more in college from the
time we both went in on because so I
went to a BTech and then and that was
because I also wanted to go to the the
college right next to it which was a
shoot I can't remember anyway so the
college right next to it but then my
girlfriend at the time one DC tech DCCCD
tech it's it was like the next to your
house abet because you didn't know the
it was it took me too long to think of
that so your girlfriend what oh so she
was a she was a year younger than me our
year under me and she want to go to East
Carolina University and I look into it
I'm like oh it's a great med program
completely not realizing that I think it
was the year a few years prior it was
the number one or number two party
school oh yeah
and so went there that relationship goes
to hell because one I think halfway into
it I was like I'm living with someone I
really don't like as a person like
outside of from like the physical stuff
we're at that age that's all like I was
thinking about no just like you kind of
suck as a human being and and I probably
sucked as a human being as well but when
you have no money and nothing to do and
you're surrounded by that person at all
times like you just you want to murder
each other and this is in Greenville
this is in Greenville yeah yeah what you
know we're familiar with growing up
outside of Raleigh and then we were in a
large group of friends in high school
who the majority of that group of
friends all went to ECU okay so we
probably had they were sparking a dozen
in this like group that we hung out with
they all went to ECU so and we saw at
least half of them kind of fall off the
fall off the map and one year at ECU so
we I understand know what happens the
the party school effect there I'm trying
to think what happened there I don't
know that's also was around the time
that I started youtubing because it what
she wanted to be
you said med program so you had some
aspirations of that yes I'm gonna be a
doctor or whatever yeah and I had the
idea that I was going to be a doctor it
wasn't I feel like it was also instilled
in me since I was a I was a kid because
my dad was like you're gonna be a doctor
gonna be the first one and you're gonna
do this and you're gonna help people and
yeah being a bio major a chem minor is
like the fastest way I'd be like I hate
everything like I can't like I can't
have a life because I'm not a genius and
so like putting in the work it was I
don't know I I kinda just sucked at
school I was not smart enough for it and
I think I was also at that point wanting
to be a doctor for all the wrong reasons
and that's pretty much just money
especially when you look at the world
and there's so many other ways that if
that was like just your goal and it not
to help people or to go into a
specialization don't do that don't
because otherwise you're just another
person contributing to the problem that
we have right now right so at some point
in there at ECU you started making
videos yes so no money
I could you know I feel like everyone at
that point is living off of like either
the dollar menu or pasta or ramen and so
you know I was I was there and I was
like oh oh I'm gonna watch lonelygirl15
videos and so I was watching that
try to think you guys have been around
forever so you probably remember Burnett
oh oh yeah Boheme stuff like that
early YouTube yeah early early to BEC
when like it was it was all about
community and then just like crazy crazy
drama problems oh and how everyone was
terrible once uh what was that YouTube
was purchased by Google because they
were gonna put on ads and ads are evil
right and I was like ads yeah well but I
mean so that was actually one of the
reasons I continued doing YouTube and
also stopped going to college because I
was just burnt out I didn't know if this
is what I wanted to do I was actually
rethinking my major no idea what it
would have been and and I go okay well
no I'm gonna double down on school it's
gonna be important and I believe it was
either Margaret which might have been
the first person I talked to you guys
remember Margaret yeah or someone else
from YouTube and they were like we're
gonna start this thing called the
partner program and we're getting ten
people and it was like Boheme zip stir
like just like old school people and and
they're like and we're probably gonna
give you like 5k a month I think is what
it was and it was nowhere near that
nowhere near near that at all but she
contacted you because you had made a
name for yourself on your channel yes
and I think how did that happen so in
that gap I think one month I guess it
was it was a 2005 where you join did you
have a youtube profile oh five because
that was like it couldn't be and then
before that right after I'd have to
double check because that's another
thing it's either oh five or oh six okay
yeah I remember that it was all four by
three back then we had star system
ratings what were you doing what videos
you went from watching videos to making
videos yeah so what were the first
videos you made my first video I ever
made which was I was smart enough to
remove it six years ago was me making a
video response to renetto to a video
where he was like hanging out with his
kids for 40 seconds and I was like it's
really cool it makes me like happy to
see that it makes me think of like me
hanging out
my dad when we'd go to the park on the
weekends cuz that's when he would get me
and he'd swing me around and it was fun
like I don't know I just I loved seeing
that and I removed that I filmed it in a
Panera Bread Wow while I was I had one
online class and I didn't have internet
at home at the time so I was just there
just messing around what were you
thinking at the time it was a way to
connect it was really a way to connect
to people I mean I was I was rockin on
myspace at the time getting excited
anytime I got a new friend that I could
possibly talk to and so YouTube it was
just it was more immediate I could see
people and and so that was the first one
for the first video that had any
substance was probably rush I think it
was rush limbaugh I always get
I always get the conservative talk guys
confused but I think was rush limbaugh
saying that Michael J Fox was faking his
disease none s not not faking it but he
was exaggerating I remember that yeah so
he was exaggerating it he didn't take
his pills and so with any film to this
ad and I was like that's like how
cynical of a person are you that that's
where you jumped and I got so pissed and
so I made this two minute rant video and
I think it got thirty thousand which is
was amazing to me at the time and so I
was like I'll do that a little bit and
then so you had an opinion you were
passionate you made the video you got
some traction so then you were like I'm
gonna go with this I've got an opinion
thing well not not actually at that
point I not at that point I had I also
did something with a bunch of buddies
the the front page of YouTube was
curated at that point yeah and so
anytime anything went up there we would
automatically jump and either make a
response or a spoof to it kind of like
what we what you see with vine now and
anyone pops on something and then
everyone else does that idea or a spoof
of it I think it has a vine actually has
a lot of ties to early early YouTube
even the the the really really bad
sponsor integrations into a place that
doesn't have ads and you're like okay so
everyone loves Wendy's right now okay
everyone loves uber right now okay great
but but yeah I oh and so we would watch
this video is try and get what looked to
be one of the first video responses or
do the exact opposite if they had their
stuff on
not Otto except video responses and they
were they would actually wait we'd try
and be one of the last because you're
kind of just guessing when they're gonna
get online and if he would be one of the
last videos that would pop up you'll be
the first one yeah so people video and I
also made fun of a lot of early
youtubers to get any attention
whatsoever so like the hill 88 I think I
might have made a fun of me me Molly at
some point just early tubers and then
you know it was it was all in fun one of
the first videos we made once we really
started trying to get traction was we
started making responsive videos too we
need a response video to wicked awesome
films punchy that got some I got some
traction and then there was these toobut
wins the pushed wins they did a
skateboarding video okay and then we did
this video where we were silhouetted and
we altered our voices like and then we
just made fun of you kids but you know
it got a few thousand views or whatever
the number was we stopped after that it
did really work for us yeah what no no I
I was gonna say that
I actually think that it was did it for
us you know I mean I think what the real
thing that did it was when one of our
videos was featured on the home page but
yeah that was like you get you to get a
look you taste a little bit of that like
traction taste attraction slogan did you
just start chasing it you know I forgot
like I was featured was a saying then oh
it was in it was that was it Magus thing
it was a turning point yeah I remember I
got featured once and it was on a video
that had nothing to do with any of my
other content I was like it was like a
video where I showed my sister existed
same thing happen to us Brett had his
son LOC react to a basketball game
Wolfpack versus Tar Heels it's still on
our Channel and he YouTube contacted us
to feature it he was in his underwear
and it got flagged and taken down and
then YouTube asked us where is the video
we said well it was flagged you took it
down like we were talking to the YouTube
you took it down YouTube YouTube was
like oh well upload it again and we'll
feature it this is it like a phone cut
Roberson yeah but the night
but then I said okay here's what we're
gonna do I'm gonna put the video back
online we'll put it back up but I'm
gonna ask you right now will you feature
one of our music videos because you know
we're actually trying to do this YouTube
thing but not with our kids in this this
is just a video of my child being funny
put it back up but please feature in one
of our videos they featured the unibrow
song and yeah and it was that that taste
of traction yeah enough people liked it
and but did you did you have like
because I think back to that time for us
it was we even before YouTube we had the
this very undefined aspiration to do
entertainment full-time it was like we
want to entertain that's what we want to
do you know we had been engineers for a
while and we knew that we we got enough
of that to know that we didn't want to
do that full-time right when you were
doing that initially because none of us
really had an idea that there was a such
a thing as full-time youtuber that
wasn't a job that existed so it was very
difficult to aspire to it so what-what
were you hoping to accomplish I had yeah
I had no idea I think that's for most of
us well most of us that didn't have like
that was back that background or
aspiration no idea I think I was one of
the Talking Heads that had a schedule
and and eventually I I didn't fully love
the opinion stuff until later when I
actually started meeting people and
seeing that I wasn't just a crazy person
talking to my camera that had actually
like either like made someone care about
the news or the world around them or it
helped form their opinion whether it was
to agree with me or not and that's when
I really really got into it but I mean
obviously I think they say Frank was the
reason that I ended up actually doing
this show because he had the show would
say Frank for one year after it ended I
feel like a month after I was just like
that every internet so boring to me
right now like the only other thing I
have is rocketboom which was going
through like weird transitions at that
point and so I was like I'm gonna do a
show and the first like two or three
that I did was a terrible terrible
ripoff of Zeze show and I eventually
just I was like oh I should just try and
find my voice like I have to because
otherwise I'm gonna be this terrible
terrible accidental parody of a really
really great person and slowly found my
voice I try to keep the videos to three
or three to four
now they're crazy out of hand 8 to 12
minutes of depending on the day but yeah
I mean that that was really it and just
like the early stuff I probably wouldn't
be here if while I was at school my
laptop just it just I forget what
happened but it just stopped working one
day and I didn't have a camera and I
couldn't get make youtube videos and so
I remember on one of my school computers
I was talking to this guy that I had met
in a stickum chat room which is also
where I met Lindsay who then would go on
to be my fiancee and just like Wickham I
remember yeah we would just all go there
and then and so this guy he's like well
I just got my tax return so and he
bought me an iMac because he liked the
video as any said he believed in me and
at this point I hadn't even created the
show and this this is back when I was
still wearing a backwards hat and I had
like earrings and I was just like a huge
tool bag and I was at channel 101 was
like courting people to make content for
TV and like I think back and I'm like if
that guy did not exist he's from a
stickum chatroom yeah he was just a
friend might even I just don't have a
computer - how did he how did he know
that you lost your well cos no I was on
a school computer oh and I was just
chatting didn't have a I'm trying to
remember if I had my camera or there was
no camera or I just chose not to and I
just I was talking and then he was like
I can help you out and I thought he was
talking with me and I got an iMac and I
got to continue making videos there's a
I'd have to look cuz I know a lot of the
videos are unlisted but it's the
specific moment when I go from being
black and white with a camera that shot
like 320 by 240 to shooting with the
eyesight and it's just yeah I mean like
with it that's what I love about early
early stuff and it's I think to this day
why I always try and test out things
where we feature people whether it's
it's a known crater that's been trying
for a while or just like the one offs
because you never know like it I don't
want it to come off like terrible like
I've gone to the YouTube space before
and they were shooting this massive
massive video and the director came over
and he said thank you because I had
pimped out one of his earlier things I
was like and I ash that you're welcome I
had no idea who this guy is because we
just like to promote things that are
cool like that's been the thing like
before there was a business model that
was not a business model there was just
a love and
passion for cool hmm and so I don't know
I think there was it's those things that
probably still keep me sane today rather
than just like staring at a screen and
going like everything is a lie and it's
all a sham and we're so all la yeah I
mean the the whole pay it forward thing
the fact that you can pay it forward to
the point where you don't even know who
who you just paid I mean that's my
beautiful thing I'm sure when we talked
to Shay you know we'll get him in here
at the table and I know that you're
gonna be more than a blip in his story
well she's been she's been probably the
most a continually appreciative person
throughout all his then later on
successes which he is 100% like a lesser
person would not have accomplished that
despite any promotion in the beginning
so I don't know but there has but there
have been cases of just like people that
you helped and also you see this now
with the next generation of tubers even
the ones that like popped two years ago
that started bringing people up mm-hm
and they don't they're they're bringing
up people that aren't like Shay I need
to see like relationships and
friendships and just terrible terrible
you know we we tease to it at the top
but now everybody's just been waiting
around to get back to this whole jerks
the whole marriage thing now you and
Lindsey mmm-hmm how long were you dating
off of stick am stick him well so we
weren't dating at that point because I I
my life so stupid and weird I had what I
thought was a girlfriend for four to six
months and it turned out to be a crazy
girl like how you give ranges on things
it's good it's very safe years 10 to 12
it depends on what you mean by is no
things so I just give ranges but so for
a while there was this girl online that
I was really into and we would talk
every day and once again I was a very
lowly kid growing up so it was all about
like this this girl that I talked to
only on voice and she had a myspace
profile she totally had to be real and
live in New York like she said alumni
and so I'm back then I'm
anyway compress this part to get to
Lindsay which actually matters I moved
to New York I like threw all my stuff in
my car moved to New York because we're
totally gonna get this place together at
what point is this and what you've
already told us at this point this is
right after the girlfriend that I had in
college okay so this I was getting
YouTube Adsense at this point or no it
was either right before or right after
trying to mm-hmm I hate my memory so you
were a YouTube celebrity you needed I
had
oh you were getting Adsense you weren't
getting yeah you were I'm trying to
think if it had to be Adsense it that
well anyway so at that point I'm like I
don't know what I want to do but I want
to go to New York I know I'm from New
York I probably have some family there
that I haven't like talked to ever
because like the last time I had seen
them I was like 12 and I never really
talked to family get out there turns out
oh the place that I totally thought we
were getting together is just like some
random house that's still for rent and
I'm up there now with no money because I
thought everything was all squared away
and we had we had like done the
downpayment in the first month this is a
real girl a real girl just don't know
who she is at all like she all we know
is that she was in I think what was
Kansas because then she so the worst
thing right so I'm up there
she she's one of these like before
catfish came out and everything she was
one of these people that like created 20
myspace accounts and they all had like
they would all boyfriend there was an
ex-boyfriend and there were the friends
and what do you mean like you're angry
at Megan oh you're a terrible like just
full-on orchestrated and I couldn't get
ahold of her and then I'm sleeping in my
car
I mean you couldn't get ahold of her
when you went to meet her in New York
where you made a down payment on an
apartment that you were gonna live in
together where I gave money on PayPal to
her to do it I'm smart very stupid
I'm a very stupid person so I'm there
and this is yeah this is over six years
ago end up having a sleep in my car I'm
freaked out cuz I'm like what the hell
happened I thought that she had a semi
violent ex-boyfriend and then on my
myspace when I wake up in the morning
and I forget where I went to finally
find Internet and any food there's like
this whole thing about how they found
make it and they like beat her up and
she's in the hospital and I just
remembered just driving blankly on I was
like I don't know she has to be lying it
has to be like this doesn't happen in
real life like this is like it was that
point where like it just starts to
shatter because I think to say that I
didn't have doubts before like they're
only so many times you can be like I
don't have a camera or later I can't
livestream like its I think it was more
believable been like if the same fit
happens now like you just want it too
much and I probably just wanted it too
much at that point I was lonely I had no
direction in my life and I was just
moving to New York with nothing in my
little I was like 93 Geo Prizm this is
like periwinkle blue just and I remember
I was like okay I don't even know where
to go at this point and I just remember
some reason I'm on the Jersey Turnpike
and I pull over into a gas station and I
call her from a payphone and so she
finally answers and she talks about how
she was like beat up and everything and
I was like I know you're lying there's
no way any of this happened there's no
way and so I I maxed out and overdraw
all my cards I get back to North
Carolina and actually in a very weird
way with without this I probably would
not have gone on further in YouTube
because at that point I ended up staying
with my mom for too much I'm sorry I'd
completely changed the whole idea I got
back none of my friends believed me none
of my friends believed that she was just
a glitch they said that I was like an
untie that I just didn't understand and
I was being completely rude to this
victim to like this girl that was a beer
on her side yes like people that I had
actually like met at points in my life
did not believe me but they like believe
this random Internet person and so I
would later found out that she also then
did this to one of the other guy friends
that were in this like stickum group
because I talked to her before Lindsey
and ones he still gives me about all
this because it's just such a stupid
time in my life but she ends up doing
the same thing to this guy and then they
did a bunch of research and they found
out she was like I guess when I was
talking to her like a 17 year old girl
in in Kansas so that was just craziness
there but anyway so Lindsay and I
Lindsay was in a group of people who
talked on yes dickham yeah with you and
another guy who both were taking
advantage of by this girl and she I
don't think she knew the other guy but
she did know of Meagan it's weird
Wow his weird that's so what's making up
this is why I hate talking about my life
because it's so weird but I feel like I
feel like when anyone people like people
look at me they're either going that's
weird
or you have to be lying and that's why I
think I also hate talking about my past
it's it's super weird I don't know well
it's entertaining
I hope it's at least at our table so
then okay so Lindsay so I'm so weird and
damaged so then Lindsay I she she never
would turn on her mic she'd always be in
stick and I was like oh this was this
little pretty blonde girl and then if
you look at any history of Lindsay
Lindsay was bigger than me on YouTube at
the time she was all about like the
Braves and her original YouTube name was
Braves girl 5 right then was like B girl
5 now alright wait I think it's I have
to its Linds loves now that's right
where she post her travel stuff but
there was like this whole thing with
like the old school and Cyclopaedia
dramatical guys and like people like
photoshopping weird sex pictures of this
like young blonde girl Lindsay and I
just remember like there was a page
where like it's literally nothing but
gifts of like her photoshopped face
getting like by two giant black do it I
was like this is on the Internet and
apparently she got crazy harassed he
believed Megan that was real but you
didn't believe that because I think that
would probably change my conversation my
opener like so I saw this picture but we
uh so we were in the chat room and then
some some random person orchestrated one
of the first YouTube gather I think the
first Youtube gathering had ever gone to
and that was Adi
see tube which is supposed to be this
like kind of biggish event for
everything like literally it was like
eight of us who were flown out and like
they paid for us to be there and three
people two of the people did not like my
videos and I was like this is the worst
time ever I'm just gonna get obscenely
drunk and so I just I did that and that
was the first time I met Lindsay and I
met her at I think was a can I hop or a
Waffle House in the morning and I was
just like this girl is really pretty but
I shouldn't do anything about it because
at the time I thought I was really in a
relationship with fake girl Megan OH
and literally the last thing I said to
Lindsay before she left when we were
hanging out was I'm so glad there's no
sexual tension between us
so we can be friends and that she's like
yeah that she left and I just remember
that and then so basically you said I'm
not attracted to you I think that were
an okay person and I don't want to punch
you but I also don't want to have sex
with you I think it's what that phrase
means okay yes loaded phrase but then
all the craziness happens and then at
some point there is a another youtube
gathering called south tube and at south
tube I end up I don't have enough money
to stay at a hotel so Lindsay's like you
can totally crash at my dorm and I was
like that sounds great and I out with
her her there that first night and then
that was the first time and you see now
I'm trying to remember because there's
also a night where mystery guitar man
Joe Penna also no it was the same night
never mind this is a completely weird
thing so the first time I ever had
relations with my girlfriend Joe Penna
was about 10 feet away
mystery comes from the mystery no she
wasn't wearing sunglasses because he
might have been closer than you thought
he was at the dark you see a tiny
glimmer of his sunglasses yeah I know
that was it that was right because yeah
Joe was coming up at the time I mean
that's the thing about a lot of the old
schoolers who are now trying out that oh
it's so terrible it's amazing it's I
didn't even remember the
anyway so that's where that relationship
started because then like a week later
she was like oh I hear maroon 5's
playing in Florida like I checked later
and maroon 5 was in Atlanta like two
days before that but she wanted to come
down and hang out oh and so yeah and so
she came down we had a blast it was fun
and then she was gonna leave and there's
this whole like sappy like I wrote a
note and left it in her purse and it was
like I wish that you could stay an extra
day and it just so happened that her
plane ended up getting or the flight was
cancelled and she had to wait till the
next day so she got to stay another day
and it was awesome and I think it was at
that point I was like okay yeah she went
back and I want to say about a week or
two later I I'm having to deal with it
now too because we're we just got
approved for a mortgage and I was like
oh I remember that terrible blemish on
my credit I left that lease because I
moved to Atlanta and just ditch the
ditch the place they uh yeah that hurt
my my credit score so I helped you
relationship that's right yeah and then
yeah and then I was in Atlanta there's
this whole shebang of YouTube money
wasn't as good as we thought it was
gonna be because it was definitely
promised out to be a lot bigger and so
then I overspent on like a few things
here there she had to hide me in her
mom's basement when they were trying to
sell the house which worked for about
three weeks until they tried to show the
place and we had just no heads-up and
yeah so I mean that's that's another
reason I love Lindsay so much she's
always had my back and she always like
even when I didn't have anything and no
one was like going yeah or no one was
even trying to get stuff from me like
she had my back man she she was like one
of the few genuine people that it's not
that I can trust it's that I know that I
can trust I think when people have had
the opportunity to take from you and
they haven't and they had your back when
you didn't have anything I think that's
that's the probably the the thing that
led to me going like oh I love this girl
because I think in any relationship you
have those feelings for the first I mean
they're they're the range right there's
the three months and then at three
months usually know it's make or break
and then you are either really into it
or are you just like there's something
keeping you there and then there's the
one to to you
and then and obviously I'm gonna ask you
guys because you're gonna have to have a
different thing but there's like
definitely something around three to
four that it's like you start not
remembering maybe what it was like
before that person was there and even
inside of our relationship we had we
broke up two times one we had a we had
it we rented a loft and I worked from
home and she took online courses and
that was a nightmare cuz you could just
hear each other all day while I'm trying
to record if she's trying to study and
it was just like how we freaked out and
she ended up getting her own place it
was like one of our her mom's old old
place that was still available how long
was that breakup
well the breakup was only for about a
week I think both breakups up actually
for well so one was a week and then the
other was like two days okay so we're
talking a relational Tantrums yeah
actually yeah when you look back on it
it's not a ladies part I'm not playing
anything this is before you you were out
you're in LA yes yeah well one happened
in Atlanta another one happened a year
and a half two years ago and I mean
that's that was another thing I was
actually ready to propose she had been
it was like that uh that lust for a
person you get when they've been gone
for a little bit like she was uh she was
like going through this whole thing
where she was like I want to see Europe
and I didn't have the time my schedule
so I was like go go do it like just like
rock it out and so she went for like
three weeks and she came back and then
and I was like okay I'm gonna propose am
I going to ring shops and I have no no
idea about rings at the time and I'm
like slowly alerting and then we had to
like call him ring shops right before I
realized that you should go wholesale
how long ago was this when you were
about to propose I want to say it was
about I hate you because you make you're
making me self aware of my ranges it was
probably about a year and a half two
years ago yeah yeah and so she answered
it came back and we had some weird petty
argument over the dog pooping in the
house like because I was like you've
been gone for three weeks so you ended
the argument with
propose no oh no I feel like that's like
the that's the wrong thing to do no I
didn't even say that until I want to say
about four months ago she never knew
until years later four months ago yeah
because she was definitely getting antsy
and in my head I've known for about
eight months since because it definitely
that whole breakup it made me like oh
like I don't know I'm not I don't know
like the world around me I'm not sure
about things but that yeah I knew again
about eight months okay by the way
Lindsay is a little bit of a soul to
have you have I ever told you about the
time she made me cry
all right so so this is you this is I
think between the breakup scenario and
now so before proposing I'm really drunk
one night she's a little bit drunk but
not super drunk to to realize that she
could totally prank me and how does she
decide to prank me but give me a fake
pregnancy test that she got from a prank
shop and I was so happy and I started
crying she thought I was gonna like reel
back in terror which by the way why
would you even test that but and I'm
just so excited and I'm like crying
because I didn't even realize I wanted
at that point but it was like this
realization to me I was like it's called
a prank or if that's called manipulation
no see growing up with with I love her
now because it's something in my blood
like growing up mom with my mom I I
think I know what manipulation has
granted when it's that close to you you
never know but but I think I was just
kind of joking so she what she thought
it was a oh she thought it was various
she learned something that if she had
wanted to manipulate oh yes she was
betting for the lot of shock and awe man
yes just kidding but here's and I was
happy and like I think in that moment
I'm just like it could be a boy or girl
and I'm happy and I get to like go
through all these new because I think at
that point and I think it when I talk
about like pushing my my past behind me
and everything I think it's because
those are the things that make
me feel and I think a lot of those old
things made me feel bad things whether
it was you know maybe fear maybe just
giddy about myself or anything but all
of a sudden I could have essentially a
new start to all of those situations
where I don't pick up that kids
childhood and I can you know live
through that kid in like you're not
having a childhood and you hopefully
have two parents that love you equally
and don't hate each other and I can be a
part of that granted in a different
position but I could do that and I think
it was like all of that came into my
head and then it was immediately ripped
away and I was like and I like I and how
did she rip it away what did she say
well no she's like no no okay no so I
get that she has a camera oh man I'm
trying to think if she had a camera as
well because I just know I was I was so
torn Oh anyway so that that I don't even
know where we were she started you
making me remember at my life you
started crying and she was like tears of
joy and in tears of devastation and then
she felt horrible about it no that was
not then it was just 30 minutes of me
going that's so that just made
red-legged raving throughout the house
but that had to that definitely had to
change or maybe not change maybe
reinforce the way that she felt about
you at that point was it like the talk
of marriage began to enter the picture
it was a Lindsay is is the kind of girl
that always wants a marriage I think for
Mike Birbiglia a great comedian put it
the best way is I don't even necessarily
still believe in marriage I I believe in
the person that I am now marrying I I
know that it's something that she wants
I know that she makes me happy I think
other than like those random moments of
doubt and like really there's just the
two that I can think of like I feel even
though I've never thought like oh I have
to get married I always knew that like
Lindsay was the person that if I did get
me I wanted to be with that person I
wanted her family I wanted to still to
this day like I feel like I'm two Phil's
I'm work Phil
then I escape from that and I get to be
Phil Phil and I get to be that with
Lindsey and like my three or four
friends and and so I've always known she
if anything was negative to the
relationship is every now and then she
would push a little bit too hard for the
the whole marriage thing like the
previous Christmas like I got her a
really nice necklace and apparently
there was something that I said at one
point somewhere that made her think that
it was gonna be a ring and the
disappointment in her a necklace is a
ring for a really big fingers gonna work
you're bringing your fingering that fat
just the disappointment in her face and
the disappointment in her stepmoms face
and I was just like oh she had talked
apparently and and yeah think of
anything it was it was the pushing but I
think she was also at that point where
you know we were together for over five
years and we'd always I'd always point
to our buddy daneboe who created
Annoying Orange she waited 10 years
before doing that and and she's like I
know like I feel like Lindsey would
still be with me but she definitely be a
different Lindsey and I don't know I
feel like we're also at the point where
it's not that you know we just proposed
and we have that like that glow about us
I mean we're right now we're making a
lot of big decisions because we did that
right so I proposed we're gonna have to
figure out the wedding in 30 days I
might actually own my first house which
I'm really really like it's all the
adult stuff and then the proposal is
online now that's there's a video that
people can watch right the proposal yeah
well no no it's not up yet we're gonna
we're gonna well yeah no there is I
don't even know what's happening in my
life yeah I'm yeah okay I feel like I've
seen it I think it was on YouTube yes my
website YouTube yeah
yeah that's right I posted the video
because I edited it myself because I was
like I have to share it because there
are all these like terrible angles where
I look like a giant fat person just my
vanity that made me edit the video it
was like the first thing I've edited and
a little bit what what pushed you over
to make the proposal I just wanted it I
think I wanted her to be happy about it
I will
like whatever that feeling is where you
know like this is the woman I'll marry
I've I had been there I just don't
believe in the idea of marriage we went
to a a wedding and I felt so
uncomfortable in this church that was
describing marriage is this thing God
created and like and I don't know there
was just like this weird thing and I was
like well I'm not getting married
because like God wants me to get married
I'm I'm doing it because Lindsey I want
her to be happy and to know even though
I don't put value in in the paper or the
Rings even though I know what they stand
for and I believe those things like she
does and because of that it matters to
me and because of that I go along with
it I know that Lindsey's like the only /
like if I hurt Lindsay and and hopefully
in the future when we have kids and and
I where I hurt those kids like that
seems terrifying to me that's the last
thing that I want and I feel like those
are all the things that you think of
when you're like I'm gonna marry this
girl after like four weeks it's but I've
continually felt that and I don't think
I would ever feel that I mean obviously
I don't I don't believe in the one and
all the others wait where we gonna say
no go ahead believe in the one Oh like
that we all have just like one other
person right you know I think that's a
little silly right yeah so you don't
think that there's a ceremony that you
can craft that would have meaning for
you it's more of this already has
meaning for her and I love her enough to
do this for her it's what I hear you
saying for her yes I mean for me when
I'm when having when I have the ring and
I get to clink it on the table and I
know that'll have meaning to me because
it's there but also it's probably my dad
instilled my dad instilled in me when I
was younger he's like there's no reason
that you have to they'd probably also
played a big role he's like it's just a
piece of paper I like I'm just remember
like my dad having these conversations
were like 6 to 8 year old me just like
your uncle he was with his with his his
now ex-wife for 15 years before they
decided to get married and then like six
months after it changed everything like
they had the wedding and I was like no
you can't go out because you're my
husband and I'm your wife and like
apparently it changed everything and so
I had those four your stories I had the
people that raised me and honestly like
other than than that like my I think I
said earlier my dad and my stepmom like
they made me believe that like people
can be there
people can have your back and I don't
and I and when I look at Lindsey even
though I think in relationships people
love each other at different levels and
it's constantly fluctuating it's I don't
know I feel like it's always there might
change when I'm at your guys's point
having 12 to 13 years but how about that
instead of me babbling I did when in
your relationships did you ever have
real breakups or little fights like me
no breakups and you know I mean we built
marriage up as some big thing that you
know there was no we didn't live
together before you got married our
first year of marriage was absolutely
horrible because it was our first year
of being together in every sense of the
word well we dated before and we were in
the same room beforehand lived in Zoey
man yeah yeah so we're in the same would
me my life so marriage was something
that was maybe it's more of kind of how
Lindsay thinks of it that it was a it
was such a all we aspire towards this
this moment this ceremony everything's
going to change after and then the next
year was how do I live with this woman
so if there was gonna be a breakup it
would have happened in the first year of
marriage but off abort this marriage you
know the buildings on fire it's coming
down why did we put a down payment on
this place its kind of how we felt about
it but I mean there was it was you know
there was love and there was a
commitment and it you got through it
that's good but they were there so there
was no breakup I mean we might have had
a fight last night that she said sleep
on the couch that may have happened to
really but I heard about that we talked
about it's awesome to and about them I
didn't I didn't end up sleeping on the
couch I'll put it that way
no way and I think we nip things in the
bud these days and I think that you know
that's my perspective too is the you
know what you're talking about with the
fluctuation of the love level which is
so true is like I think that you know
our culture has definitely made it all
about just the romantic connection and
it's just like you don't you don't see
many movies there's not it's not a
really exciting story on TV or in a
movie to just talk about commitment
you want to week we're constantly
presented with images of the moment of
romance you know that's what that's what
a romantic comedy is that's what a love
story is it's the moment where these two
people came together and it was fiery
passion and that kind of thing and
that's something that Epsom flows with
any relationship and I think that's you
know getting married at a young age I
mean we were both like right out of
college my wife wasn't even done with
college we got married what it
represents on this side of it is this
like yeah we've made a commitment and
not that is if there is a lot of romance
we have a great relationship we're still
in love with each other we still date we
still experience the you know each other
relationally in the way that we did when
we were dating but it's it's like it's
not based on this at times you
experience that but it's not just like
about that it's not just this like we're
compatible because I think the fact is
is that yes we are compatible in a
relative sense but no you're only
compatible with yourself ultimately
right no one is really compatible with
someone else all 100% and 100% of all
the ways you need to be or that you
could be and 100 spins at a time that
you conduct life with somebody
and so right so when you get to that
point where it's just like all right you
know right now it's very difficult to
love this person it's very difficult to
have a romantic feeling right now in the
midst of this thing it's like for me the
marriage represents that commitment I
hear what I hear you saying is that well
the commitment is there I don't need the
formal a rain
in order to maintain that commitment my
big thing right because there are those
moments of romantic there are those
moments of you take care of each other
when you're sick but how how do you
react in a relationship when over two to
four years that person I mean even
sooner when those per that person
changes like you do you grow together
but also how do you how do you get along
and how do you deal with it when one
person just feeling like a toll that day
and they're just a when I'm a douche
just like a completely miserable
terrible self deprecating I hate myself
what's the reaction to that is it shut
up you're stupid or is it you know
something that helps or like there is no
answer I think it comes down to that
what works for that relationship because
I can sometimes be a hard person to live
with if I if I end up bringing my day
home and that's why I have been living
this whole like two different fills but
I think if a relationship works or not
it isn't based on the good it's based on
when the relationship is shitty and when
circumstances are shitty do you fall
apart or is your relationship something
that only works when the environment
around you is perfect and that's when I
see like a lot of the divorces it's like
everything's good especially like
friends from back home you know our
parents are paying for most everything
you know and I don't think there's
anything wrong with living with the
parents for a few years I went the
different route but it's definitely like
when life happens like my relationship
with that girl before all the craziness
when it when we were in college didn't
work out and a big part was like when
things weren't perfect and everything
didn't work we hated each other just
like and we had no desire to make
anything better and with Lindsey it is
that like still years and I I don't it's
more than I just don't wanna go to sleep
angry it's because it's a little bit for
me but also because I care about that
person and I don't want to have messed
up that person's day and
I don't know it's it's something weird
and deep and even a little bit
analytical like me and now I'm feeling
even though it is that makes sense
I mean you talk about changing I mean
were as humans we're constantly changing
it's just to you to me marriage is
making a decision to do life with
somebody and there's a commitment that
we are going to live life together and
so we're gonna change together you know
old couples they look alike because they
live life together
you know that's my goal is my wife's
better looking than me my goal is to
look more like my wife when I you know
that's really what it comes down to just
try not to sleep on the couch today
she's listening right now baby it's also
why you shouldn't get a dog because you
also begin looking like your dog mm-hmm
you know and if you have a dog for the
time that you have that dog the wife and
you and the dog all began to merge and
if you have a dog the dog wins it's not
even a merge but it's in there's an
evolutionary kind of pace to be being a
person that's just constantly changing
and to me it's when everything when
things go bad it's I fall back on the
commitment that we're we're doing this
together we're in this together we're
gonna get through this together and it's
it takes a lot of work constantly - it's
not just when it hits the fan but it's
every day it's the small things you know
it's well I think it also helps you even
eventually or not that in the long way
be happy I feel like because you put so
much on that commitment that you always
have that that option there because I
feel like in everything especially in
relationships there's a million easy
ways both to to escape or to mess it up
but like when when you look at that that
harder road if you really really believe
it I mean you're living that life
there's the end there's a reward - that
is a reward of that harder road what do
you think the reward is true
companionship
you know the willingness in your
building I mean you know I may be mature
I think you
very fitting that when you thought that
Lyndsey was pregnant you cried and you
thought about what that would be like
cuz I think that that's a big part of it
too I think that you know traditionally
you know the romantic view of
relationships is a relatively new
creation that the primary purpose of our
relationships is is romance in the past
it was like the primary reason that men
and women got together was so they could
procreate and build families and create
and basically contribute to society and
just continue carrying on the human race
right hmm that continues to be a big
part of it and when you so you create
this environment in which children can
come and you know now we've got the mug
O'Laughlin family and the McLaughlin
family is my wife and I and these two
little boys you know it's like you you
start seeing it's just like yes this is
this is so much bigger than me and just
wanting to be with this one individual
person I'm kind of building something
that needs to be solid you know it can
just be like you know what
I am I met this other person and you
know we're having a real good time
together I'm just gonna leave this the
situation behind you guys figure it out
III think that that's one of the rewards
one of the rewards is this is this
family and this this legacy it's not
easy there's absolutely nothing about it
that's easy it would probably just be
easier to just be a bachelor a George
Clooney that moves from one lady to the
next you know so I mean for me a big
reward is just like I feel like there's
something bigger than me happening here
yeah and you know I mean you talk about
oh I'm moving on to the next person now
I mean that's what my dad did
mmm when I was 2 and I don't want to
recreate that you know I mean he had a
tough road after that and so did I as a
kid you know I don't want to give that
to I want to build something different
you know and so I think that I was very
calculated and very scientific about my
approach to engagement and seeing
marriage as this huge threshold that it
this means something that I'm going to
I'm gonna change the pattern that was
set by my dad mm-hmm and I'm gonna set
the foundation to create to build
something like what right like what you
were talking about that is tremendously
rewarding and ultimately doesn't create
all these painful barriers that I had to
come overcome as a kid to become Who I
am
in one sense I'm thankful for those
things it made me who I am yes but it's
exciting and it's rewarding to to say to
have the prospect of teaming up with
somebody a wife and saying I'm gonna
build this thing that has other little
people that then get bigger and you have
to reprimand it is the the partnership
that's interesting because there was a
time where I thought like okay I want a
woman that's like she's doing the bigs
like she's like a businesswoman or she's
out there doing all these things because
that's like that's what you do you got
to work for it and I don't want like a
house housewife or anything and then I'm
like I realize like if Lindsay didn't
have my back and she what didn't play
the support role
I would crumble I would fall apart and I
think the thing that pushes me is it's
real I mean this is awesome and I like
talking to you guys and actually dig the
podcast because we get to like shoot and
have like real moments that was I to be
the name of the podcast for was what
real moments are so we didn't feel like
you you know go over well with our
audience so we call it ear biscuits ear
biscuit is that what it is yeah welcome
to ear biscuits then my mind goes do a
completely not a real place that I'm
like oh well the merchandize it's
literally like all my successes that I
get like when I go to any stupid LA
party and I get props for I'm just like
cool thank you and it might be because
it's like we're years and and and I
don't want to sound like I'm just like
blase about a position it's just that
it's just we're creating things and and
the the real moments from it are when
and when we get to meet people at like
VidCon and stuff like that but other
than that it is this weird not real
thing for me like 90% of the time if I'm
not like pushing a Lee Newton or a Joe
Bereta and hoping to create something
for them it's just it's this machine
that I'm a part of which has done very
well by man as gives me it gives me
opportunities but like a family that
sounds awesome like human beings like I
was what I found out or what I thought I
found out I was like oh I'm not a broken
person and I'm not gonna die alone even
though I'm gonna raise this thing it'll
probably put me in a nursing home you
know like that's where my mind went and
I don't know I was just like okay real
life's happening real life is happening
and it's not just this game that I do on
the Internet and that was I think that
was where I was like okay this is this
is life I want to live life mmm and and
have people around me well we wish you
continued success on the business front
and on the personal front and yeah let
us know when the babies start coming oh
yes well there it was our conversation
with Phil DeFranco handed and I would
how would you describe it raw at points
there you talk about it the guy has an
amazing life you know I feel like he he
he wanted to apologize a few times about
his story but I mean I had no idea maybe
I should have like read Wikipedia or
something before we talked to him no
that's that's the fun and having the
conversation and thank you for being a
part of it we're gonna do this again
next week it's another conversation with
another person can we say who it is
well I guess we should be non-committal
if we know who it is they might they may
back out after it's all lined up but it
will happen and if for some reason you
have not seen any Oh Phyllis work check
out the philip defranco show on youtube
he's also the man behind SourceFed and
SourceFed nerd you know go check it out
if you haven't check out again if you
have
all right you can hear us next week or
see us on other places in the meantime
[Music]
[Music]